so let me summarize what the steps that
we've taken are to do this differential
analysis so when you're trying to
analyze a continuous mass distribution
the first step is to pick some arbitrary
mass element a small but finite size
mass element somewhere in the middle of
the mass distribution you don't want to
pick one of the endpoints because the
endpoints are special you want to pick
an arbitrary point somewhere in the
middle pick us and then pick a small
mass element at that point so small but
finite size analyze the forces acting on
that mass element so write down Newton's
second law the equation of motion for
that mass element that will give you
what what the action is what the forces
are on that element then go to the limit
of an infinitesimally small element that
will give you a differential equation
you can then separate the differential
equation and integrate both sides to
solve the differential equation and then
finally you can apply a boundary
condition something you know about one
or the other of the end points and that
will allow you to solve for the function
of interest at any point along your
distribution